one of my favorite things to do is go
camping for me there's nothing better
than getting outside breathing in some
fresh air and taking a swim in my
favorite river
have you ever jumped into a river and
felt that the deeper cooler water closer
to your feet was moving faster than the
shallow warmer water at your knees
that's a current which is the word we
use to describe how water or even air
flows within a larger body of water or
air
but what causes a current well let's
start with the sun
the sun actually heats earth unevenly we
know that it's hotter near the equator
and it gets colder as you go towards the
poles
near the equator the sun's rays hit
earth's surface more directly while near
the poles the sun's rays hit earth's
surface less directly in both regions
the same amount of solar energy is
hitting earth but near the equator this
energy is concentrated into a smaller
area and near the poles it's spread out
over a larger area so the regions near
the equator get more solar energy which
makes them warmer and the regions near
the poles get less solar energy which
makes them cooler
this uneven heating of earth also
affects air pressure where it's cooler
near the poles cool air will sink making
the air pressure high but where it's
warmer near the equator warm air will
rise resulting in low pressure this is
where the terms low pressure cells and
high pressure cells come from
the low pressure warmer air at the
equator rises into the upper atmosphere
where it cools and flows away towards
higher latitudes away from the equator
because the air is now cooler it starts
to sink again and creates a high
pressure band near these latitudes
this process repeats and creates a
pattern of high and low pressure bands
from the equator to the poles
we know that air flows from areas of
high pressure to areas of low pressure
this creates air currents or winds
now you might think that these winds
would blow in straight lines from high
to low pressure areas but the global
wind patterns which we call prevailing
winds look like they curve to the right
in the northern hemisphere and to the
left in the southern hemisphere this
curving has to do with the rotation of
earth and is called the coriolis effect
as these prevailing winds blow across
the surface of the land and water they
also push against the surface of the
ocean and produce wind-driven surface
currents which help to move ocean water
here's what the global pattern of ocean
surface currents looks like
like wind currents ocean surface
currents are also curved due to the
coriolis effect we can see that in these
currents that are traveling north and
south which curve to the right and the
northern hemisphere and to the left in
the southern hemisphere
together as the surface currents of the
ocean connect they form giant rotating
systems of ocean currents called gyres
the currents that drive these gyres
extend from the surface to about one
kilometer down into the ocean and help
to move water all around the globe but
these gyres aren't just moving water
they're moving heat energy as well
water is pretty good at holding onto
heat it absorbs from the sun
so as the water in our oceans moves
around the world through this gyre
circulation the water also carries heat
here warm water generally moves from the
equator to the poles and cold water
moves from the poles to the equator
but the ocean has other deeper currents
that are affected by differences in
temperature and density remember how we
talked about areas heated directly and
less directly by the sun and how that
results in low and high pressure areas
same thing with water except that water
density is affected by both temperature
and salinity which is a measure of how
salty the ocean is
cooler and saltier water is more dense
so it tends to sink just like cool air
whereas warmer and less salty water is
less dense and tends to rise just like
warm air so with these deeper ocean
currents water actually moves vertically
or up and down
for example water near the poles gets
very cold it also gets very salty
because when sea ice is formed the salt
can't go into the ice instead the salt
stays behind in the water and so the
water gets saltier or more saline
together the coldness and salinity makes
the water very dense causing it to sink
deep into the ocean
in other parts of the ocean wind drags
deep water up to the surface and a
process called upwelling these vertical
currents are connected by horizontal
currents at the surface and in the deep
ocean
collectively this system of currents is
known as the overturning circulation you
might also hear it called the global
ocean conveyor belt so here's a map
showing the overturning circulation this
map might look a little bit strange but
here we're looking at earth from the
south pole so australia and the southern
tips of africa and south america are
closest to the center of the map while
europe most of asia and north america
are at the edges
now if you follow the currents in the
overturning circulation you can see that
they flow all over the world's oceans
from the southern ocean around the south
pole to the pacific the indian and all
the way into the north atlantic
like the currents in the gyre
circulation the currents in the
overturning circulation also carry and
disperse heat energy all around the
world
here i am back in my favorite river
wading around and enjoying currents of
cool water flowing around my feet
and even though this river is small the
currents that flow through it are
similar to the global wind and ocean
currents that flow all around the world
so these currents connect in our
atmosphere and oceans which means that
we are all connected so
currents connect us all